[Music]
is there any food you refuse to eat
shadro do you all know what chadrow is
it's a sack of fish eggs
it doesn't sound appetizing won't eat it
all right i need to leave a question for
the next chef
[Music]
what or who inspired the first original
recipe that you called
gosh i guess it has to be my dad
i made my dad's meatloaf and kind of
made it my own
because i loved it so much and it
comforted me so much and so now my dad's
meat love is my meatloaf that's part of
passing down recipes so that would be
the recipe that became my first original
i get to write my question
to leave for someone else
what's one food that you love but you're
embarrassed to eat in public
um
[Music]
i really have to think about this
take your time
i mean a food that i really love i call
night cereal which is just cereal that
you eat at night oh i love rice chex
with like freezing cold rice milk and um
flaky salt and a little bit of maple
syrup great cereal
what ingredient is your secret don't
tell nobody ingredient
okay
secret but i would say worcester
worcestershire sauce worcester sauce
worcester sauce you may know it from a
bloody mary drink
but get it out of that drinks cabinet
and put it into your stews your soups
it's delicious this umami i highly
recommend it but it's a secret
now i'm in a writer so
my question is
to get you in the mood what is your
go-to first song
on your dinner party playlist that is
an excellent question i am
super old school i think that i still
listen to songs that my dad listened to
while we were growing up so
anything by otis redding is probably
playing or anything by harry belafonte
and now
um i'm going to leave a little
note for everyone
[Music]
this wall
looks like my brain
these are carla thoughts this is a small
spot i start to talk but then i have to
go over here the thought is a little bit
long but then i'm like oh wait but hold
on and i swing over this way and then
i go down here
oh this is a really highlighted thought
this is me
on a good day
me on a good day
me on a good day polka dots oh my god i
love polka dots
i feel like i look really good in here
[Music]